Hello, and welcome to this
connected data world talk on
graph analytics
versus GraphML.
Probably, most of you
have heard about,
the recent uptake in graph
analytics and
GraphML for a large
number of use cases.
And I actually truly believe
graph is the future of AI.
Just if we look
at what companies
like Uber and
DeepMind are doing,
if we look at,
what's happening
in drug research
or computational
chemistry. So, also,
if we look at Gartner trends,
there is a clear uptick in,
how we can leverage graph.
And I think here,
this audience can
probably truly
appreciate this uptake,
which many of us probably have
seen coming from
the last years.
I'm Jorg.
I'm the CTO over at RankoDB,
a graph database.
So I actually do this
on a daily basis.
And, also very
passionate about,
graph machine learning
and GraphML.
Also, for example,
teaching an a weighted
course on that.
So but let's actually
dig into it.
Let's also see what
this talk is about.
So if you're talking
about graph AI,
we can often mean very
different things.
So I always try to kind of
classify the complexity
of queries
we try to answer as follows.
So the most simple
things we can
look at are graph queries.
So those are queries
which should
be able to, be
answered from any,
graph database.
And it can simply be like,
who can introduce
me to another
person in our
social graph here
on the right?
So in the end, basically,
what is the path
going from one
note to another
in this graph?
If we want to get
more complex and,
as I said, often from, like,
an algorithmic level,
we first we have to
keep some state.
We have to make
sure, to actually,
find something
globally in a graph.
And then we actually come to
the realm of graph
analytics or
graph algorithms.
And, for example,
questions we can answer here,
who has the most
connected persons
in this graph? And
you can already
see we have to, a,
look at the entire graph, b,
we have to keep
some state, like,
how many direct neighbors,
how many direct
connections does
a person have.
Then kind of see next level,
and this has
really been taking
up over the past year,
is graph machine learning.
So graph machine learning,
allows us to deploy, yeah,
statistical machine
learning to
alter our graph or to
add, for example,
edges, to add node features.
And with that, we can do solve
tasks such as follows,
predicting potential
connections.
So we can see that
here on the right,
who should actually
be connected
to another person,
but we can also predict other
node features that
can, for example,
be the churn
probability of people.
So here in this graph,
imagine just each node having
a little feature saying how
likely is that
person to churn.
So with that, I often
get the question
asked, like, what is actually
the difference between regular
ML and GraphML?
I really feel
the value of GraphML
comes in from
certain properties
of real world datasets.
So a default
assumption in more
traditional machine
learning is,
I independent and identically
distributed data.
Meaning, if we here
on the right again,
our social graph
and we will try
to to churn,
imagine how likely
someone to leave our favorite
social network,
we would treat each person
independently, and then try to
predict those probabilities.
But if we think about it,
what just what will happen if
all our friends have just left
the same social network?
So we are very likely to leave
that as well as we'll
just be left with,
like, a so lonely
node out there
without any connections.
That is the one part.
Second part, probably,
we'll also have
similar reasons
to lease the network
as all our
friends set. This is actually
an assumption
which is true for
many real world datasets,
and it's called homophily.
And that means
that neighboring
nodes are similar.
So in this case,
we would have
a similar likelihood
to leave that networks and all
our neighbors, or at least it
wouldn't be totally
independent.
Of course, in
traditional machine
learning, you could
create an extra
feature such as
how many of your
direct connections
have recently
left that network.
What you see is
this is an explicit
feature we have to create,
we actually have to
consider upfront.
So, let's dive
a little bit more
into what we can do or what
actually graph
analytics is about.
Graph analytics sometimes also
refer to network analysis.
Feel free to ping
me about the exact
difference. Happy to get into
the debate about that.
But, this is actually analysis
applied to graph based data.
It's, used across many fields
from fraud detection,
marketing,
supply chain management,
recommendation systems,
law enforcement,
cyber, etcetera.
And if we drill down,
we can also treat it as a way
of unsupervised learning.
So, let's take a look at what
we can do with that.
So for example,
who is important
or influential?
We saw that already
in the previous
example about, our network,
who is the most
connected persons.
But we'll also
see shortly that
there are many other measures
of what it means
to be important
in a network. And,
again, here,
you can already
see this is kind
of like unsupervised
learning task.
We just have to graph.
We don't necessarily
have a training
target, but we can
still identify,
who would be important or who
not till we kind of
get an outcome.
Other things, can
be if we have,
a chain of events,
what is the connection or also
topological sort,
what is kind of a valid order
in those partially
sorted graphs.
And An important question,
especially in
computational chemistry,
is, for example,
are two graphs the same,
which isn't as easy to answer
as you might think.
And as there exist
a large number
of algorithms for
that as well.
And then if we go into
fraud detection,
what is unusual in a graph?
So where are
certain patterns,
which might indicate,
fraudulist behaviors?
So for example, in
money laundering,
certain chains of
money going around,
being transferred,
back to that same
person, or just,
also large aggregates of,
money being transferred
from, like,
one account split up and then
eventually arriving at,
the destination account.
Maybe just as the last
example here,
also very important,
what are
distinct subcommunities
in the graph? Again,
many real world datasets have
certain subcommunities.
If you think back
of our social,
graphs there, they often were
like those independent
components,
or, like, independent
subgroups,
more or less independent,
of people usually
centered around
one or more influencers.
And often, it's
quite important
to identify those
communities.
For example, again,
this can also be used in fraud
detection. Where we
try to identify,
for example, similar items,
similar offerings,
in into subgroups.
Usually, graph algorithms are
specked by a number
of graph algorithms.
And so here, just a very crude
approach of kind
of classifying
what what is all out there.
So on the one hand,
we have search or
traversal algorithms.
So that can be, Node or Edge.
This can be breadth
first search,
depth first search,
which probably most
of you already
covered, in some kind of,
computer science or
mathematics class.
Otherwise, pathfinding,
and that would be the simple
example we saw also
in the beginning.
I want to find, like,
how can I get from
HEP or in a social
network? Who can introduce me
to a specific person?
And then we come to,
the more fancy term for what's
actually important out there,
and that would be centrality.
And so, for example,
what are important nodes in in
a network, in a graph?
And, those are
also referred to
as central nodes,
hence the notion centrality.
If we now, take
a look on the right,
so here we have
the sample graph,
and, I try to identify several
different notions
of centrality
because it really depends on
the what you want to achieve.
So, for example,
the most simple one,
and that was also the question
we had in in the beginning in
the introduction slide,
what is the most
connected node?
And this is referred to degree
centrality because
the degree,
the number of
edges a node has,
is basically that
criterion here.
The other one, is
closeness centrality,
and that refers to
which nodes are,
on average, close to
all other nodes.
So, for example,
if you're trying to build some
kind of distribution center,
which from where you can reach
all nodes on average,
in the fastest,
that would be
the closeness centrality.
Last, there's also betweenness
centrality, and that's,
referring to,
what is how important
are certain
nodes in connecting
multiple subgroups.
And you can already see if you
drop this node
here as in between
as the, purple node,
you would actually,
split that graph
into two subgraphs.
There, of course, exist,
even many more
different centrality
measures, but just to give you
feeling for it that
this is a very
important task with
also many important,
different algorithms.
And next, quite common task is
cycle detection, And this is,
for example, given my database
background, as this is often
used in database
systems to identify,
cycles or a deadlock
detection.
If one transaction
depends on another,
then probably we have to abort
one transaction.
And, if you want
to imagine that,
that's actually a cycle
in the dependency
graph of those transactions.
And it can also be
used in general
network analysis.
So if you're trying
to plan, like,
a routing or
telecommunication networks,
also cycle detection,
can be an important step.
And then, last,
we already touched
upon that is
community detection where we
want to identify distinct
subgroups in our graphs,
which might have
different behavior.
And, again, this
could, for example,
also be in
a telecommunications network,
where, which helps
us to generate
our routing or in
cases like a fraud
detection where we want to
identify distinct subgroups,
which we then can classify as
either fraudulent or not.
Let's next move to, GraphML.
So GraphML is machine learning
applied to graph based data,
and this means we're actually
coming up with
a trained statistical
model. So as you
might know from
traditional machine learning,
when we we are training a deep
neural network or
something else,
this comes in two steps.
So there's first a training
approach where we are training
our statistical model,
and then the second step where
we actually leverage it to do
some productive work.
This is called
the inference part.
And, this is really split,
and this is also distinct from
analytics where, basically,
this is like one task.
I have my graph.
I'm doing my analysis,
and this is then my outcome,
my my inference in one step.
Graph eval typically
is a supervised
machine learning step,
not not always,
but typically,
where I have kind
of one target I
want to train for.
And the challenge with graphs
and machine learning is graphs
are unstructured data.
So the question is how
can our favorite,
neural networks,
or other also support vector
machines deal with that?
And this is where we come into
the realm of graph
embeddings.
So graph embeddings, often,
or you usually
try to represent
our graph in some
form of a vector.
So here we have
one example for
note embeddings.
So we try to embed
the notes in
a in a graph form, and,
we just choose
a two dimensional
embedding. And if we
already plot that,
we can see, often,
this is already very helpful,
to distinguish
certain subgroups.
This is the Karate
Club example.
Feel free to beat
up about that
or visit our, workshop,
on graph machine
learning where
we'll dive more
into this example.
But we can already
see often by
just embedding it, in in a,
vector space. We can easily
apply here linear separation
between those two groups.
And, again, this
is due to the fact
that, real world datasets,
real world graphs often have
those properties such
as in this case,
again, homophily
that neighboring
nodes will inhabit
similar behaviors.
Then, usually, this is done,
with graph neural networks.
So graph neural networks,
what do they do?
They basically take a graph,
go into the embedding space,
turn it into another latent
representation of set graph.
So, that transformation step.
Which you're using high level
frameworks, you often don't
really see that,
step in the background to go
through the embeddings.
But, basically,
we come up with a new latent
representation of set graph,
which can then
be used for node
classification, graph
classification,
or for example, link
prediction output.
There are a large
number of use
cases and, I would say this is
still growing, this field.
For example, Uber
Eats is using,
graph machine learning,
graph neural networks for
recommendation use cases,
which food should
you order next?
Molecular or, computational
chemistry is using,
graph machine learning for
practice covering.
And, for example,
also DeepMind,
if you think about, maps,
this is in in the end
also a graph.
So they are using
graph machine
learning to improve
CTA predictions,
for Google Maps.
If we take a look at
these use cases,
they are actually overlapping
quite a bit. I mean,
there are certain things which
we would only do in GraphML.
For example, link prediction
gets a bit
challenging in Graph
Analytics, And there
are other tasks,
which are clearly
part of the graph
analytics domain.
But for a lot of tasks,
we often have a choice of what
we want to do. And this is
actually what the remainder of
this talk about
is is about when
should we choose
in this middle
space here when
we actually have
options? What are
our trade offs
between choosing
a graph analytics
solution and a graph
ML solution?
First question for, for this,
is probably performance.
So how long does it actually
take to get a result?
In graph analytics,
this really depends
on the algorithm.
But as I said in
the beginning,
typically, we have to look at
the overall graph,
and we also have to recompute
that or rerun that
algorithm for
any new tree and
any updated graph.
So overall performance,
it can be really
fast if we have
a simple algorithm,
but especially on
large graphs,
often performance
is is a challenge
out here.
In graph machine learning,
this performance
or the performance
cost is actually split across
the two parts. So training,
we need to train
our statistical
model and then, inference.
Modern, graph machine learning
is often using
inductive techniques.
So we don't actually need
retraining if we have a new
query or or an updated graph.
And, also, with that,
the inference part,
which is what we
typically care
about if we need
an a quick result,
is also constant
in graph size.
So, in the end, the in
graph machining,
we kind of we pay an upfront
price into training,
but then often,
again, it it slightly depends
on the model complexity.
We can achieve pretty fast
inference times,
which is, as I said,
then also constant in terms of
graph size. Also,
we can leverage specialized
hardware for that.
So, for example, GPUs,
they are really
good in training
and also doing inference
on, on those,
neural networks.
And, so in the end,
if we really care about fast
inference performance,
graph machine
learning can give
us this edge here because we
train a statistical model.
And then once we have some,
we don't have to go
across the entire
graph but can just
look at the narrow
field of that graph.
This comes at a trade off,
and that trade off
is, a curiously,
or if you see
the vice versa side,
it uses an approximation.
So the next
question would be,
does, the use case actually
require exact results or are
approximations sufficient?
If we take, for
example, a look at,
health care. In health
care, probably,
we really want
exact results and
approximations
depending on what
we are doing, but,
that might actually
be a challenging
thing similar in finance,
but it depends
a little on the use
cases. Whereas if
we do the Uber
Eats product recommendation,
if we only use
an approximations there,
that's actually okay
because, overall,
we won't get, like,
really exact results anyhow as
we're still dealing
with humans.
And so having an approximation
in our algorithm
is actually fine.
The other aspect
of when we talk
about those approximations or
at least statistical
model aspect of,
graph neural
networks also comes
to reproducible results.
Imagine, you're in finance,
you're retraining your model.
You would expect
at least similar
results. So
the question is how
reproducible are the outcomes
in the end.
Graph analytics,
we have an analytical
model, so it's,
reproducible,
and also accurate
to our to our
algorithms because
we are just really following
the algorithmic steps.
But keep in mind,
it might actually
be too expensive
to run on large graphs.
So, accuracy
doesn't really help
us if it comes down
to too large cost,
and we can't fully,
leverage that in the end.
Graph machine learning,
on the other hand,
is using a statistical model,
so an approximation.
And so the accuracy depends on
data and model.
So how much data do
we have available?
Often, I've often seen
machine learning,
trying to be trained with just
too small or too
unqualified data.
So I think this is really then
crucial also for
your accuracy.
And, on the other hand,
we can also control the model
complexity of our
graph machine
learning models,
but keep in mind,
it's still an approximation
out there.
And this also relates then,
or leads over to
the next item,
and that's explainability.
So, the ability
to reason about
the inference results.
So understand why a certain
decision was made.
Why was this,
why was this graph
classified as a?
Why was it classified as b?
Or going back to our social
graph from the beginning,
why was a certain
person classified
to be likely to churn?
Graph analytics, again,
it's an analytical model which
we can reason about.
Graph machine, on
the other hand,
we have a statistical model,
which is often a black box.
So trying to reason about our
graph neural network
probably will be,
challenging, but
this is actually
an active line of
research trying
to understand how
can we make,
how can we make
machine learning
models more explainable?
How can we more understand why
a certain decision was made?
Scalability. So the ability to
really scale to large graphs,
large datasets,
which might even,
require a distributed
computation.
So graph analytics,
the scalability depends
on the complexity
of the algorithm.
But as we talked
about earlier,
often or in most cases,
we have to look at
the entire graph.
So, there's already, like,
some kind of limit.
And, the other aspect
here is that,
growing or updating
datasets is,
challenging. This
is also called
trans activity,
and it refers to
imagine the we
are Facebook. We
are LinkedIn.
Our social network graph is
isn't going to be stable.
There are changes
all the time,
new people joining
or people churning.
And, the question is now,
if I want certain results,
what does it mean
for for my graph?
In graph analytics,
often, as I said,
this is, trans activity.
We have to recompute
the results,
from scratch,
which, of course,
is also costly in terms of,
scalability,
especially in terms
of large graphs.
Graph machine learning,
on the other hand, it, again,
it depends a little
bit on the model,
how how much it scales.
But, again, keep in
mind, we have this,
trade off between,
training and,
inference. So training,
it can often be a really long
but offline process.
And then when I want
to do the inference
, I can rely, or utilize some
results I have out
of the the training
process. Furthermore, again,
a kind of
a complexity precision
trade off. So less
complex models
also would evaluate
and train faster.
And so I I have
kind of, like,
a knob to control that.
About growing and
updating datasets,
graph machine
learning or modern
graph machine learning
as, for example,
GraphSAGE, they are
actually inductive.
So we can update
our data set,
and we don't have to retrain,
the entire model
from scratch,
but we can still utilize that
trained model to classify new
new nodes or change
parts of Deepgram.
So, Zan, if we go to, like,
a direct comparison,
so we took,
actually ran the number
of algorithms.
And, you can see
there are certain
things which we would
just solve in the,
in in the space of
graph analytics
such as sort shortest
paths, etcetera,
connect components.
There are other
things where we
actually have options such as
vertex or graph similarity.
And there are
other things which
we would only do
in the GraphML
space such as
edge prediction.
And especially in that realm
here where we have
two options,
let's take vertex and
graph similarity,
we we can see
the, trade offs.
Graph analytics, basically,
doesn't need, any train time,
so it's great there.
But on the other hand,
it will be pretty,
bad or we will incur that
performance cost at
inference time.
We do the same with
graph machine,
we can actually have the trade
off between training time and
inference time
and split it into
one offline and one
online process.
Trends, or inductivity slash
transductive notes, in,
using graph machining,
we can utilize a trained model
also if our graph changes.
But, of course,
as Tom said in,
cost of, explainability
and precision,
it's going to be
less explainable.
First, we have,
a generated model.
And also the precision,
it will be an approximation,
of those results.
How to choose that?
That was a lot
of information,
but the simplified version or
the questions I would
ask, first of all,
should always be,
is a simple model sufficient?
Graph analytical models are
usually simpler and,
keep it short and simple.
So I would always
choose a simple
model over a more
complex one.
Next question would be,
is is there a need for, like,
an exact answer,
or are we approximations?
The if we are approximations,
this could be an enabler for
graph machine.
And if we really
always need very
exact answers,
we'll probably
stay in the realm
of of graph analytics.
But keep in mind,
this might actually
be unfeasible,
depending on the data size.
And this is exactly
the next question.
The smaller the data sets,
the more likely,
we are happy in
the data analytics
space. The bigger
the data sets
might actually mean
we need We we are,
a, able to train
a a larger model,
but, b, also, might require,
graph machine learning.
What are our performance
requirements?
And, again, this can be split
into two parts.
Are we okay with
a large offline
training process,
and then faster
serving times,
or, are we actually okay with
just running graph
analysis from
scratch? We have a need for
inductive learning.
I said, like,
since this is a subpart of,
three and four, but,
also refers to,
like, how dynamic
is our graph,
how often is our
graph changing.
And then last,
do we have a need
for explainable
results that we
can easily look at,
explainable machine learning,
techniques? Or, we, again,
might have a tendency to use,
graph analytics
over graph machine
learning. So,
that was a lot of
information. I
tried to capture
some information here,
where to go next
if you want to
learn more about it.
So first of all,
if you want to
learn more about
graph databases,
graph databases in action,
if you want to
learn a bit more
about how to model data,
the practitioner's
guide to draft data,
then, graph algorithms,
is nicely covered
in this book.
Graph machine learning,
also kind of as
a lead over from,
graph analytics is covered in
graph powered
machine learning.
And then if you really
want to dwell,
deeply into, graph
machine learning and,
also refer to, like,
the embedding processes graph
representation
learning as this
is a really great free ebook,
which is out there.
Furthermore,
there's a a really
great course at Stanford about
machine learning
with graph and
a number of blocks out there.
Having that said,
thank you so much
for listening.
Also feel free to, visit us.
We have a number of,
other information out there,
both on the side.
Otherwise, there's also talk
from Data AI
Summit about graph
powered machine learning.
And if you're
really interested,
there's, kind of, AZ
workshop tomorrow.
And, then there's
a longer version
of the graph powered machine
learning first steps,
over at O'Reilly,
also, taught, by by me.
But I would first recommend
visit the course
tomorrow, and,
then let's see about that.
Thank you so much
for listening,
and, feel free to
ask any questions.
If you don't, feel,
open or incentivized
to ask them now,
also feel free to reach out.
Thank you so much.